Carly's with us in Massachusetts hi
Kylie welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
babes thanks for taking my call sure so
my husband and I we just started the
baby steps - and we're finally combining
our finances and his his parents had
loaned him some money back in 2011
before we even knew each other
and they told him that there's no rush
on paying them back no interest well
come to find out there has really not
been any payments made on that over the
last couple of years and I'm now to the
point where I
I just want this gone I don't like
lending money to family and I'm
wondering if it would be okay for us to
take out a personal loan through a
credit union to pay the parents back in
full get that out of the way or if I
should just continue to monitor the
situation and we pay them back
personally every month how much debt do
you have not counting your home 16 to
them and what else 6 Leo 16 to them and
we probably know only about 20,000 left
36,000 36,000 and you're dead free
except your house yeah and what's your
household income we are around ninety
thousand okay and so how quick do you
pay off thirty six thousand dollars
making ninety my goal is I want to be
debt-free before I turn 30 which is next
September so my my goal is hopefully
before that I can keep going as intense
that I'm going then
yeah probably by July yes okay and the
other twenty thousand dollars in debts
what how many of them are there uh there
is two credit cards in student loans
okay and
so a few different student loans so also
16000 is the largest debt it's at the
bottom of your debt snowball yes okay
but they're they're paid off a hundred
percent by September if you don't go get
ready Union yes is there toxicity in
this relationship
not necessarily there's been you know
just some some minor comments me to me
how even before we get married about how
I can pay them back and and I just I
just don't like lending family any money
I don't disagree with that I don't want
you to owe family money I don't really
want you know anybody money but I really
once you get rid of this loan but the
point is you're only relieving you're
gonna start paying large large payments
on this very soon yeah in order to make
your September go yeah so it's really
not that big a deal if you want to go
get if you want to go get a credit union
loan that's fine if you just wanted to
just really roll up your sleeves and
start punching on this thing you're
gonna have it done by September okay so
I think the the only upside of doing it
that way is you're not kind of smacking
their face right if you throw that
student if you go borrow the money and
throw it at them that's kind of like
thumb and your nose a little bit after
they've been waiting all this time with
no interest and no payments okay it
makes them think that you know like you
were upset about it or something okay
did you see what I'm saying and if
instead you just got real aggressive and
got them paid back then that's more like
wow look at what they did I'm proud of
our kids okay we we are planning on
having a sit-down meeting with them this
weekend to discuss you know the actual
amount that we both agree on that's owed
and to go forth with what ever planet we
decide yeah okay once you start paying
them like five hundred bucks a month
because you're and just put that in the
budget it won't change the debt snowball
it won't change the end result of
Timber either way okay and that'll make
you feel like you're doing something
okay well we're gonna start paying you
500 dollars a month if we come to
agreement tonight
now if in this meeting you get some
weird toxic stuff and you need to clear
the slate just run over the credit union
borrow the money I don't have a problem
with you doing that if I thought you
were going to be there for three or four
years I tell you to do it okay but
September is pretty quick yeah and it's
not that big a deal big a difference um
you know but if you told me like you
know sometimes I have people call me my
dad loan me the money on my house
because he wanted to get the interest
just did of the mortgage company and I'm
gonna owe him for 30 years no we're
gonna go get a mortgage and pay him off
I'm not doing that crap Thanksgiving
dinner tastes different when you eat
with your master and the borrower is
slave to the lender absolutely so yeah I
get your sentiment and I completely
agree with you I'm just saying because
of the short timeframe
I don't know how hard I would push this
and you know it's all gonna be over by
September so you can even be gentle in
the meeting next week gentle gentle
gentle yes thanks for the call